Why did Mrs.Tomato turn red ?
She saw Mr. Green pea.
Watching adventurous movies is always a fun experience.
We are always mesmerised by the awesome visual effects.
Most of us are aware
that they are created by using a Green screen
while shooting the movie.
But ever wondered how this works?
And out of all the other colours,
why are Green coloured screens used mostly?
Can we use other colours?
Let's find out .
Imagine a person who wants to teach some Astronomy lessons
by showing fancy stuff in the background.
All she does is add a Green screen in the backdrop.
How does this help her?
Well, the answer lies in the technique called Chroma Keying.
It's a process carried out by
various computer application softwares.
What exactly do these softwares do?
Let's understand with our example!
In our video, we want Stars and Planets in the background.
Currently, the whole background of a video is just Green.
So we tell the software to remove the Green colour
from each scene in the video.
This makes the background transparent.
Now, the job is simple
the software fills the transparent background
with an astronomical scene.
The final result we get is the combination
of the character's video footage with the astronomical background.
This is the Chroma Keying technique.
It's basically a technique used
to remove a specific colour from an image
and replace it by some other image.
Now that we've understood what Chroma Keying is,
can you tell me why the Green colour is specifically used?
Think about it!
Well, to know that let's understand with a situation.
Here, instead of the Green screen
say we use a Brown screen as the background for our character.
Now obviously in the Chroma Keying process,
we will remove the Brown colour from the background.
Notice what just happened?
That's right !
When we remove the Brown colour from the background ,
the same colour tone from our character is also removed.
We can now see that the result isn't something what we want .
Alright, what if we take this colour as our background?
Again in the post-production we get an absurd result.
This gives us a hint, doesn't it?
Yes, for the background,
we have to choose some contrasting colours
that do not affect our skin tone or hair colour.
And which are those colours that are not contained in our skin tone?
The natural skin tone of the human body
doesn't have Green and Blue colours.
The same goes with our natural hair colour.
Do you see any shades of Green and Blue colours?
I doubt it!
So by default, Green and Blue screens are used in the backdrops.
But usually, we prefer Green screens more often than Blue.
Why is that?
The answer lies in the Digital cameras.
They are designed in a way we see colours.
What does that mean?
Our eyes are more sensitive to Green colour
than any other colour.
And Digital cameras have sensors
that capture the Green colour accurately.
So, Green being highly luminant
is easier for computer softwares to identify
and remove during post-production.
Another reason is that the Green screen
requires less lighting setup than the Blue screen.
Also, subjects are likely to wear Blue outfits
more often than Green ones.
It's very difficult to avoid blue colour outfits.
But what if the person wants to wear Green outfits?
Well, in such rare cases, the Blue screen comes to our rescue .
All right ! Consider this challenging situation.
We want to create an action block scene of two characters
with some adventurous background.
Here, one character is wearing a Green outfit
while the other one is in a Blue outfit.
What should we do here?
Do we have to shoot characters with their respective
Green and Blue backgrounds separately,
and then merge them together during post-production?
Or can be used both Blue and Green screens
together to shoot the scene?
Or is there any other better way?
This is your Kyu box to explore.
Let us know your findings in the comment section below.
Do share this video with your friends,
and press the bell icon to get notified
whenever we upload a new video.
Be curious and Happy learning !